bonjour excusez moi il a été transféré
en 4e 3 nous va t'asseoir à côté de
cette jeune fille
j'en ai marre des crampes depuis deux
ans qui s'était dessins des nues mais
moi d'être super ses dessins comme
excuse moi je te promets on parle un peu
ta sexualité
dupuis essence gasoil laisse tomber et
kate des récrés sont les victimes de
demain t'as jamais rêvé d'avoir une
indépendance absolue
aussi loin que tu veux sans avoir rien
demandé à personne on se fabrique une
voiture
qu'est ce que tu vois une maison et là
une maison avec des roues exactement
tél
on apprend au la rampe à la liberté
on vit dans le passé
mais c'est juste que de moore pour être
mon ami il faut avoir une sacrée
indépendance d'esprit
dumas cote de popularité
je dire à 8
les stats en asie
il paraît que je ne fais pas mal fixé le
games
bon moi
pour moi